Welcome back to understanding quantum information and computation. My name is John Wattress and I'm the technical director for education at IBM
Quantum. This is the 16th and final lesson of the series and the topic of the lesson is fall tolerant quantum
computing. Over the course of the three previous lessons, we've seen several examples of quantum error correcting codes which can detect and allow us to
correct quantum errors as long as not too many of them occur. If we want to use error correction for quantum computing, however, there are still many
issues that need to be reckoned with, including the reality that our quantum gates, measurements, and state
preparations are themselves likely to be imperfect. So, for instance, if we're going to perform error correction on one
or more cubits that have been encoded using a quantum error correcting code, then we're going to have to do that with gates and measurements that themselves
have a chance of not working correctly. And that means not only failing to detect or correct errors, but possibly
introducing new errors. In addition, we also need to perform the actual computations we're interested in performing again with gates that aren't
perfect. And we certainly can't risk decoding quantum information for the sake of performing computations and then
re-encoding once we're done because errors might strike when the protection of a quantum error correcting code is absent.
That means that we have to figure out how to perform quantum gates directly on logical cubits that never go without the
protection of a quantum error correcting code. This is a tall order, but it is known that as long as the level of noise
falls below a certain threshold value, it is in fact possible to perform arbitrarily large quantum computations reliably using noisy hardware, at least
in theory. And we'll discuss this critically important fact later in the lesson. Here's a brief overview of the
lesson. We'll start out with a basic model for fault tolerant quantum computing including a short discussion
of noise models along with a general methodology for implementing a quantum circuit fall
tolerantly. We'll then move on to the issue of error propagation in fault tolerant quantum circuits and how to
control it. In particular, I'll discuss transversal gate implementations which offer a very simple way to control error
propagation. Although there is a fundamental limitation that prevents us from using this method
exclusively. I'll also talk about a different methodology involving so-called magic states which offers a different path to controlling error
propagation in fall tolerant quantum circuits. Although it isn't the only known method and finally the lesson
concludes with a pretty highle discussion of the threshold theorem which I alluded to just a moment ago.
This theorem states that arbitrarily large quantum circuits can be implemented reliably so long as the error rate of all of the components
involved falls below a certain finite threshold value. In general, this threshold value
depends on the error correcting code we use as well as the specific choices we make for fault implementations of
quantum gates and measurements but not on the size of the circuit being implemented. And this gives us a good reason to believe that large-scale
quantum computations will one day become a reality. We'll begin by discussing a basic model for fault tolerant quantum
computing which is naturally based on quantum circuits and quantum error correcting codes. For the sake of this discussion,
let's imagine that we have a quantum circuit that we hope to implement such as the one shown here. This happens to
be a teleportation circuit including the preparation of the EBIT. But the specifics don't really matter for this discussion. And you could imagine that
this is any other quantum circuit, possibly a much larger circuit that includes state preparations, unitary
operations, and measurements. This circuit, of course, represents an ideal, and an actual
implementation of it won't be perfect. The natural question to ask is what could possibly go
wrong? Well, there's quite a lot that could go wrong. For instance, the state initializations generally won't be
perfect. Of course, the unitary gates won't be perfect and neither will the
measurements. And moreover, the cubits themselves will be susceptible to noise, including decoherence, at every point in
the computation, even when nothing is happening to these cubits and they're simply storing quantum information. In other words, pretty much
everything could go wrong. There is one exception though or at least that's a typical assumption and
that is that any classical computations that are involved are probably not going to be faulty because for all intents and
purposes classical computations are basically perfect. So for example, if we run a classical matching algorithm to
compute corrections for surface code errors, we really don't need to worry that this classical computation might be faulty. But anything that directly
involves quantum information could be. Of course, we need a precise model through which we can associate
probabilities for various things to go wrong. And if we wanted to, we could come up with as complicated a model as we like to hopefully reflect whatever
actually happens in reality. If the model is too complicated, however, it might end up being difficult or impossible to work with or to say
anything interesting about. One very simple example of a noise model that people often consider
is the independent stochastic noise model where errors or faults affecting different components at different
moments or in other words, different locations in the circuit are independent.
For instance, we could say that every gate fails with a certain probability, that bit flips and phase flips happen to stored cubits with a different
probability per unit time and so on. But the assumption is that there's no correlation between different
errors. Now, you might object to that model because there probably will be some correlations among
errors. For instance, there's probably a small chance of a catastrophic error that wipes out all the cubits at once.
Or perhaps more likely, there could be errors that are localized but nevertheless affect multiple components.
And nobody suggests otherwise. But nevertheless, this model does represent a simple baseline that in
essence represents the idea that nature is unpredictable, but it isn't malicious and it's not trying to intentionally
ruin quantum computations. There are other arguably more realistic noise models that are often considered. And regardless of the
model we choose, if it turns out that our model leads us astray and we learn something new about the errors in
whatever system we're working with, we can naturally formulate and consider different error models. Next, we'll take
a look at a basic strategy for implementing quantum circuits fall tolerantly. So let's consider a given
logical quantum circuit, meaning an ideal quantum circuit that we're interested in running. For instance, we could consider the same circuit as
before, which is now stretched out a little bit because we're going to need a little bit more space for the fall tolerant implementation of it. First